alright everyone welcome to another
google+ hangout where I interview
successful entrepreneurs and get secrets
to help us grow our business today I'm
really excited to have Edward kundulun
the show with us and he is an expert on
search marketing local search digital
marketing mobile marketing youtube
marketing all sorts of on to help you
grow your business and I've had ad on my
radio show before and he's a leadoff on
my website and said hey we gotta do a
Google+ Hangout welcome aboard Edward oh
thank you thank you for having me well
do you wanna for everybody listen you
want to just give a quick intro on your
business and what you're all about yeah
actually we started back in the early
nineties 94 as an e-commerce company and
and we were basically creating websites
I thought the internet was really cool
place to sell things and I didn't want
to be a walmart I wanted to have
separate individual stores selling you
know very vertical type products and so
we had like twenty two different online
stores um back then you couldn't call
somebody up and say hey go to your
website so we sort of have to do it
ourselves a merchant bank came to us and
said hey you know we want to put small
business owners online we want you to be
the back room and I said okay cool it's
an easy way to get clients I didn't have
to do any of my own marketing so they
were sending us like 50 clients all ages
it was crazy cooking people and so we
would put up these little shops and they
know and then you know that was through
the 90s and they got sold to another
bank who didn't want to do that anymore
and it was like oh I guess where we're
gonna get clients from now so we had to
do some marketing and we had clients
come to us and we're there yeah okay I
lost you I throw ourselves a merchant
banking said hey we put small business
owners online we want you to be the back
room and they said okay cool it's easy
way to get clients I didn't have to do
any of my own market it you could just
cause that something else like 50
clients where are you
I'm still here I can see you okay cuz I
lost you okay um but i'll just keep
going i'll just keep right on one um and
and so then global was born and you know
getting on directories and doing alpha
romatic domain names like 1a you know
whatever wasn't working because that's
the way directory is obviously fact then
we're listening Google came about and
then we sort of said hey this is really
cool and I'm I'm a marketing guy anyway
so I got involved with the online
marketing that's where we pretty much
stayed and we just sort of evolved with
that we pressed involved with Google and
Bing to be fair so then that brings us
we went through some iterations of names
as we changed our focus and the most
recent his business creator because we
really focus on local search marketing
now and you know it's it's really know
we like the tagline we make small we
make local businesses grow ask us how is
our new tagline so that's that's where
we are today cool and so what kind of
businesses can best benefit from local
search marketing any business even
national businesses can it was people
doing more and more local searches on
their mobile devices and you know
restaurants lawyers are big niche right
now or big push or attorneys they seem
to benefit greatly from it but any brick
and mortar any small shop anyone because
again people majority of searches are
taking place or local searches and you
really need to be found locally and you
need to be found mobile so and that's
then that's a local event so I can't
think of one that wouldn't benefit from
local sorts morphin so you need to have
a location right you got to have a
physical store that you want people to
come to to benefit from it is that right
yes okay great I'm just thinking myself
right like I'm I'm based in Toronto for
the
most part but it's a I don't I don't
want people coming to see me so you know
local may not be the right fit for me
but if I have I'm thinking my
investments you have a salsa dancing
company here in Toronto I want that to
be found locally absolutely perfect ah
so what mistakes of people making you
know entrepreneurs busy people right
tons of stuff on the go they're not
knowledgeable for the most part on local
marketing what mistakes are they making
and and what are some easy ways to fix
it well I think the biggest mistake they
make is buying into the
five-hundred-dollar website the website
is really your window to the world which
your foundation that everything else is
going to be built around for local
search and your let me take that back
you don't need a website for local
search but it's it's I think it's
important in these days I mean you can
get found on citations and directories
and you know yellowpages.com and places
like that but i think the power of your
website is is really very very important
and I think they make the mistake of
buying into these you see these TV ads
all the time you can get a free website
or anything free sound with entrepreneur
because they have very little money we
have another cliche we say as me fix
five-hundred-dollar websites so i think
that's that's a big mistake any other is
that they try to do it themselves they
try to do your local marketing
themselves without having the expertise
to do it so what are the things you jump
into a SE que Edward you know what I
need to do this I need how what do I do
well we always do an evaluation to see
where the rat first um that's important
because you know I don't want to give
somebody the huge budget if they already
have some things already done and then
we look and see how well it's been done
and then we go in and say okay here's
what we need to do we were very
logically step by step and we do it
based on their budget if somebody has a
very large budget we to do things much
faster but you know citations are
extremely important these days for local
search mobile marketing having a mobile
responsive website either a separate
mobile web
cider of mobile responsive websites
important again people just learn more
and more searches on mobile devices we
really need to be founder you know and I
think we talked a little bit earlier
before we got started about video video
is very important for local search it
really is it's a powerful tool to get
your message across and more and more
people there's higher conversion rates
with video um there's there's a you know
it's easier to rank a video it's 53
times according to forrester research
it's 53 times easier to rank a video
that there is a web page on Google so I
think those are the things that people
have to consider I'd want to create a
website sorry a video that talks about
my business that has my kind of keywords
in it and is a quick overview of what
I'm doing yeah yeah and then so a let me
just let me just interject as well I
mean we always start off with a we call
the corporate video which is you know
things about the company and you know
all the good things about you know what
you dealin who you are but I think you
know it's important to do a video every
month or every other month and they can
become in different formats I don't have
these very large productions and that
should talk about your services or
products on video testimonials are
extremely important we signed a client
signed up with us yesterday and it's we
just finished we just finished actually
a couple months about two months ago we
just finished this website we launched
it last week we just finished a
corporate website the corporate video
rather and now we're going to be doing
testimonial videos for him um again very
powerful so the video is much more
powerful than just text and then the
companies are putting it on their local
google plus page their youtube channel
is that the best way to do it we
syndicated for them we put it on their
channels we put on our channel which is
very powerful we put it on vimeo we put
it on SlideShare we're getting tons and
tons of video traffic from SlideShare um
and and you know there's there's other
hosting sites that that work very well
also so and
and you can't just put it up you have to
build links to what you have to do some
back linking to it so nope and that
makes a big difference as well so the
process so if I'm working with you and
saying you know what wow this is like
I'm listening talks I go out so
important but like I I can't do that
myself I mean I need to get somebody in
to help me can you manage that process
remotely or do you have to be their
local to help them do these videos are
remotely we work with as far as the
videos go we have two companies we work
with that are ones in Florida ones
actually in Canada and they have crews
all over the country that they they work
with and they hire for the link for the
big video production for the regular
videos that we do if you can provide
high resolution slide the high
resolution images of some of your
products will work with you to develop a
script and then we'll make a really nice
voiceover video Adam and those are very
very powerful as well you don't need the
big production videos and and as far as
working with clients most of our clients
ironically are not from my area most of
my clients are from Florida North
Carolina you know California almost I
replace but where I live and we did we
do that from you know we do it through
phones and email I probably haven't met
ninety percent of my clients how about
getting the founder the person running
the company on video telling their story
why they started it what they're
passionate about yeah that's usually
that's usually the first video what i
call a corporate video that's that's the
first one we like to get done because
that's that's I think a very powerful
introductory tool you know again we put
it on their website we blog it we
syndicated through social channels um
and you know all the other distribution
we just talked about again those are no
very powerful tools for getting
backlinks and for getting getting a
traffic to your site and getting good
conversions do you coach people through
that because for a lot of people it
never made a video before and they feel
like they're terrible
camera you know they're nervous and
they're stumbling they don't like how
they look on on film yeah I could be a
scary process for a lot of people who
are going through for the first time
yeah and i'll give you the feedback i
just got from the client we just didn't
with and that was actually a local
client that was one of the exceptions
for my clients the video production crew
comes in the producer helps them write
the script and they get information
about it and um you know after like the
second or third take he was very
comfortable and the production company
is very very I mean they do this all day
long and then had a deal of people and
make them comfortable so that really
isn't a big deal you know he saw himself
on camera goes oh I was sweating a
little bit it's the first time and it
was kind of funny because you know he
was so worried about Easy's an engineer
and they were ill oriented obviously it
was like well can we remove the sweat
Luke holding up really ok yeah it's okay
don't worry about it nobody's gonna blow
it up full screen anyway you know it's
you'd only see it when you blow it up
but basically it's it's these guys the
people the companies we work with really
do hold the hand of the of the business
owners and yeah hey let me reiterate
it's not the only way to do a video and
we do videos like we're just talking now
on on you talked earlier to me about you
know we can do this as a video and the
other part of the video is you know if
you have high resolution images of your
products and things that you want to say
about your products it's a good way of
getting the message out there in fact a
lot of the videos you see out there on
YouTube are you know product videos and
there's really no person there there's a
voiceover and we take care of the
voice-over we have many different
voiceover actors and actress physic that
do that for us well so you're suggesting
at least one video every two months
every single or double month you want to
have a new video coming up on your
website that's to me you know it's about
dominating the search results for your
key
birds and you're going to have more than
one keyword so you want to optimize the
videos for different keywords so yeah
the answer to that is yes more the
better yeah they're fairly affordable
they're not they're not terribly
expensive so it's not something that you
know something to cost you thousands of
dollars for each video right okay so
cool so that's video you talked about
citations and you know my understanding
is that is if you get you know a
tripadvisor feedback and link your side
or people leaving reviews and other
sites and mention your company that am i
barking up the right tree or my in left
field here no you're close i mean um
there's two components of what you just
said one is a citation and the other is
review site and some review sites are
citation sites a citation is any place
where you can get your name address and
phone number listed that Google's going
to find and Google looks for consistency
so having your name address and phone
number on these different sites like
super pages and citysearch and google+
and and bang local and and oh I mean
it's just this there's literally
thousands of these different sites and
some of them are very vertical ringing
it's just for specific businesses um but
you know having your name address and
phone number out there to be in being
consistent as what's important and then
the other component where you talked
about is basically reputation management
or reviews google loves reviews we all
know that it's important and better than
the ring obviously no reviews are
extremely important for a local search
because people look at those reviews
they see how many stars you having your
listing and if you have four or five
stars vs somebody that you know might
rank ahead of you filling has one or two
stars you're going to get to click
through and then people do you know
investigate companies before they do
business with them so again it's
extremely bored right so I me so I guess
I see the citations as something that is
you know work that has to be done you
know the directories to submit to and
and you just got to go out there and
submit them be the reviews I'm assuming
you need to get the business owner
involved with to help to try the word
and ask people and and there lies the
problem
oh okay it's not as easy as you think to
get reviews i mean people give reviews
freely when they're negative right no go
to restaurant have a really bad meal see
how fast you get a negative review go to
a restaurant have a great meal you know
it's just not something people even
think about right listen xpect how do
you encourage it um ask for reviews you
know and and in a dentist office what we
do is we set up a little kiosk a little
lat it was actually two tablet and ask
people as they leave the dental
dentist's office would you please leave
a review for us it's fresh in their mind
and they'll I usually do it you know if
they have the time to do it as opposed
to here's a piece of paper and we've
tried this here's a document on how you
can go to google and leave a review for
us or how you can go to to yelp and
lieber you for us um you know take this
home and when you get to your computer
do it most people just throw that piece
of paper out so the kiosk concept
actually works pretty well for some
types of businesses and then like I said
I do have some documentation put
together step by step that business
owners can give to their customers on
how to leave a review for them why my
restaurant how do I do that how do I
encourage your foods you recommend
having a kiosk at the front and saying
hey when we do a way out I think that's
a great idea I think it's it puts people
right there in the moment you had a
really great meal I'm gonna leave your
girl leaders at review right and then
they would have to I guess login right
they'd have to have an account at your
advisor or any of these sites yeah
that's that's true and that's the other
setback you can't go to they have to do
it through their account I can't do it
through yours so that's just the way it
is no it's it's it's a any other problem
you know the other thing with reviews is
I think people forget that when you when
you get a review even a good review you
should respond to it and it's on a
business owner business owner should say
hey thank you for that great review know
and we
really appreciate it people ignore the
good reviews and then and then also your
problem is business owners when they say
negative review get very irate and and
combative and that's the wrong approach
the tech when you approach the tech is
okay we screwed up we did wrong you know
here's what i want to do to make it up
to you and make that make that you know
client with a customer who probably will
never be another cust you know who'll
ever walk into your store again make
them come back in and get a second you
know people to have a second chance you
know with that customer okay so every
single review i'm responding to good or
bad every review you want to have the
business owner leave a response yep yeah
and then for the bad ones how do you
turn it around so you have any examples
from clients who had something negative
and you know they turned it around to a
loyal customer um not without mentioning
names but in general I think you know if
you did somebody wrong if you gave them
bad service that's something that you
know you can apologize for and ask the
customer to contact you for more
information so you can help so they can
help you rectify the problem you know
and it really depends on on the type of
business and and the review I mean what
they're complaining about you know I've
seen complaints we've gotten we haven't
done work with some of these companies
but some of them come to us for
reputation repair like especially hotel
they just have a bad review small little
mom-and-pop hotels and it's just you
know the paint is horrible or this is
horrible or that's horrible and the
business owners not willing to fix it if
you're not willing to fix it and frankly
you deserve the negative you're good
right there make sense yeah yeah it's
know it is what it is it's if you're a
little dive off the side of the road on
the way to atlantic city then you know
what the only thing about it you're not
gonna you're not gonna book into any
rooms right so when we talk about video
now we talk about citations what else
what's another kind of cornerstone of
the work that you do up in business
mobile mobile marketing making sure that
their mobiles their their website is
mobile responsive or arm if they don't
have a website that's responsive and
they don't want to build any website we
will build a mobile version of their
website you know we need to make it can
be for people to you know once they get
found on a mobile device not make sure
that people can interact with their
website in a convenient fashion and not
you know after you uh you know squeeze
the page to read it or work now that's
not a good thing as most people found
most people will just go to the next
website right to be able to make that
decision so if I have a I'm an
entrepreneur can i make a website I've
got a you know I've got a restaurant and
you telling me go mobile how do i how do
i justified you look at my analytics and
say hey but after traffic coming from
mobile you got to make your Abba your or
your mobile version of the site how do
you kind of justify that to the punch
prayer oh I don't even have to look at
their analytics I you know it's it's
over no this year Mobile has overtaken
desktop for searches that's all you
really need to know I mean it's if more
than half the people are searching on
their mobile device you know Google on
your mobile device why would I not have
a mobile website or mobile responsive
website that that's going to allow them
to interact with my business and call me
and you know the percentage of people
coming in after they do a search on
mobile and find you and you're coming in
the door buy something from you online
or whatever is extremely high it's up to
eighty percent sucking the 80s and I
don't have the be the number of the top
of my head but I know it's over eighty
percent why wouldn't I build a mobile
website you know it's cheap enough it's
not that expensive you know if you're
going to rebuild your website you know
think about building it as a responsive
website again you want to address your
audience and that's a big audience to
leave you know on the table yeah
interesting
you guys do advertising oh you mean like
effing don't pay per click or you know
google ads or facebook ads or Twitter
ads that you put wait we do we do
pay-per-click we do google the edwards
obviously we do bang with your facebook
we do some Twitter advertising for some
clients we do display ads on mobile
devices as well and we do the
retargeting over the retargeting
advertisement requires another powerful
tool right so for those you know who may
not be familiar with that it's you visit
your site and then you go visit another
site and your ad shows up on that side
only because they revisited yours there
yeah yeah not like a people-people
probably seen it and not really realize
what it was is it's it's the first time
you know if you I remember when I was
buying a car a couple years ago I was on
a car site and I went over to Facebook
and all of a sudden all these car ads
were displayed on facebook oh isn't that
coincidental there's no way this
retargeting they got me you know cuz
you're the marketing yeah this is what
this is this is just what it was coming
out I wasn't all that a wearable you
know aware of it and all son okay yeah
you know what we gotta get involved with
this this is just way too cool so if I'm
you know mantra okay i'm watching this
and feeling ok yeah you know what I have
this restaurant I really need to grow
this I don't know where to start what
what's the first thing that you do
what's like the biggest hater the
quickest it to get this thing started
searching for momentum with it um the
first thing i would like i said earlier
i think i would do if they came to me I
would do a website evaluation to see
what they already have we have tools
that go out look at citation sites to
see if they're listed and sometimes
you'd be listed but not you know they
they didn't claim their listing and if
you didn't claim your listing you're
losing that quite a bit because a lot of
these places allow you to put photos and
you know specials
and your your menu and things like that
and you should take advantage of that
makes it much more powerful tool for you
so it's not just a name address and
phone number you're actually using it as
a platform for for generating more
business um and so that was that's the
first thing I like to do and I think a
lot of the times people forget to
optimize their website especially for
local search because you know the [ __ ] a
couple years ago was or you don't really
need to do anything to a website for
local search um it's not like national
search it's not like international sort
of global search well the fact is one of
the things one of the criteria that
Google's looks at is is how well a site
is optimized for ranking local and and
so you have to make sure that the
service area that that you you operate
in is is on your website it's part of
your title tags part of the description
is part of your content on the website
so that's important so I think the first
thing we always do is we look at the
citations will look how well the site is
awful and then go from there and
everything else is sort of like follows
after that but though you have to have
the depth of the foundation before you
start building the house and the
foundation is really know the site
on-site optimization and get those sites
out there optimized and social social is
extremely important so what do you help
clients build it Twitter camp and their
YouTube account and get back there yeah
we optimize the social accounts and you
know we write content for distribution
syndication and we also do the
engagement because an important part of
social social is the new link building
and its really where you know when you
put things in out there your content
whether it be written content or video
or images another important tool that
you can use especially places that have
you know graphically pleasing products
like well a restaurant I mean you know
new wonders with the restaurant under
foot on on some of these sites that
delicious to the social sites and um
you know so we get the content
regardless of the format out to these
social sites and help build backlinks on
also generates your fan base and any
other thing you know the other part of
that is you need to engage with people
it's not just a matter of throwing and
stuff out there and doing back like it's
engagement is very important so on so
many comments on something again you
know you start that working you start
that the conversation going back and
forth and that's something that most
business owners don't have time for not
something that we can do for work so
you'll do that for the entrepreneurs as
well you'll handle all the engagement in
social interactions yeah you know I I
know just for clarification we do a lot
of different components but they're all
components of what I you know it's local
search marketing this it's everything
that a small business needs to succeed
online arm in the in the local market
this is we touch on movie video of the
citations the social and the mobile you
have to because of all important pieces
there's a lot of you knows a lot of
companies out there that only get one
piece of it and I think you know your
missing or the entrepreneur would be
missing a lot of those components and
they would have to go to another vendor
to get them and I like to try to bring
everything in house on the one umbrella
so I mean that's why I we offer all
these different things 11 any word thank
you so much for spending your time today
for people who want to learn more about
you when the services you offer what's
the best way to find you arm ww business
creator plus comm is our website um you
can contact us from that we're marketing
at business creator plus com we'll get
back to you right away if you contact us
and we'll be happy to talk to anybody
about you know their project I'll throw
that link up in the description as well
as people can easily click through on it
Edward thank you so much I really
appreciate the time thank you it's for
my pleasure ok your first we'll hang out
in the books yeah thank you
all right take care annoyed for what